c'est le jour j le projet de loi que
nous attendons depuis des semaines sera
présenté cet après midi en conseil des
ministres attendus par les retraités
pour la revalorisation et l'indexation
de leurs retraites attendue par les
fonctionnaires attendu pour le prix du
carburant le prix de l'alimentation je
veux que ce texte puisse être votée en
fait on a une majorité de droite
libérale et ils sont d'accord sur le
projet l'extrême droite comme les nerfs
comme la majorité sont d'accord pour ne
pas augmenter les salaires ils sont
d'accord pour ne pas toucher au capital
puis plusieurs semaines tous bénéficient
d'une ristourne de 18 centimes sur le
litre de carburant
cette aide devrait progressivement
disparaître d'ici la fin de l'année
remplacé par une indemnité carburant
uniquement pour ceux qui roulent pour
aller travailler le salarié qui va son
entreprise et doit pas avoir de
problèmes pour faire son plein
l'alternant qui doit se rendre son
entreprise et qui habite encore chez ses
parents il ne doit pas avoir de
problèmes pour financer son plein
objectif est très simple de couvrir
quasiment l'intégralité de vos frais de
carburant on va à nouveau signé ce
chèque jeudi c'est un chèque sans
provision qui va être mis dans une poche
des français mais tout en étant prélevés
dans l'autre parce que quand on fait des
chèques de l'autre côté on augmente les
taxes et les impôts les dix huit
centimes d'euros ça coûte 800 millions
d'euros par mois ned ciblée sur les
travailleurs ces deux milliards d'euros
pour toute l'année donc voyez c'est pas
du tout comparable c'est bien la preuve
ne voulons pas de quoi qu'il en coûte
nos finances publiques ne nous le
permettent pas c'est l'effondrement du
thon de gênes s'est ouvert ce matin vous
souvenez de ces images chocs de
l'effondrement qui avait fait le tour du
monde c'était il ya quatre ans quarante
trois personnes avaient perdu la vie
selon l'anp des procureurs les
dirigeants et gestionnaires de
l'infrastructure était conscient du
risque d'effondrement l'hémorragie en
deux jours 59 membres du gouvernement
dont de nombreux ministres quittent
leurs fonctions c'est sans précédent
dans l'histoire politique du royaume uni
est justement dans quel état sont les
ponts en france un rapport du sénat
révèle que 35 mille pont serait
considéré comme dangereux
la situation pour lui n'était plus
tenable il va quitter la présidence de
son parti conservateur et donc à terme
le poste de premier ministre qu'il
occupait depuis trois ans on se souvient
qu emmanuel macron avait dit un jour ça
n'a jamais été officiellement reconnue
mais c'est dommage avait il dit c'est
dommage qu'un aussi grand pays soit
dirigé par un clown savait pas beaucoup
fait rire les britanniques et un coup
beaucoup moins sinistre que senna ski
par exemple
vous trouvez que senna ce qui est un
clown outre
je suis le premier ministre n'était donc
rien qui provoquerait votre démission
franchement monsieur le président le
travail d'un premier ministre dans des
circonstances difficiles lorsqu'il se
voit confier un mandat colossal c'est de
continuer et c'est ce que je vais faire
il a près de dimension incroyable
que tout le monde rêve air comme une
seconde fait à salamalecs devant devant
devant l'apparition en vidéo de du
président et nasri sauf que vous pourrez
voir aussi une critique politique de
nasri c'est clairement la volonté du
parti conservateur qu'il y est un
nouveau leader du parti et donc un
nouveau premier ministre
et je veux que vous sachiez que je suis
triste aujourd'hui de quitter le
meilleur job du monde aujourd'hui c'est
la langue de coton on nous met de
l'éther on nous endort on les compromis
dialogue accord et ainsi de suite et
ainsi de suite et ça se répète vous avez
un un étalage de formules creuses pour
quel état d'esprit vous êtes
écoutez sereine et concentré
c'est important cette journée
bon
allez 1